hi tasty fans I'm dick Avedon and I'm
here to do two play-by-play cross-buy
how to make the best fritters for a
tornado so here we are in our kitchen
arena ready to make some big plays with
a special assist from the quicker
picker-upper using a microwave and
bounty here to make the bacon is an
all-star move and frees up pressure on
the overall cook time I love bacon are
you serious nothing like the
unbelievable smell of some crispy bacon
and what a way to strike the morning
some beautiful bacon and eggs and here
we go we yet another clutch play use it
bounty to speed up the broccoli momentum
I'll be honest with you I was never a
broccoli lover of growing up my mother
would always say Richie you've got to
eat your broccoli try it it is loss of
baby but I Kappa the leg we'll get some
bench players out here too like the eggs
and the cheese and the chives hey when
I'm home get ready to watch a game a
game day man I can't wait just to relax
chill out lay on that couch and enjoy I
can't wait to play the color commentator
role and critique and evaluate what's
happening during a game that's just the
nature of the beast man when you've been
involved with the game as long as I have
we are in the final quarter for this
dish and it's really getting heated time
to kick this recipe and the overdrive
quickness becomes essential in the big
20 get ready knowing new teams finding
their strengths their weaknesses you
better be quick mentally physically and
emotionally bandy is a W for this recipe
look at it go soaking up all that grease
it's unstoppable Slam Jam BAM what a way
to finish audition this is absolutely
perfect for any game day party it's
quick to bake full of flavor and great
finger food but easy service that
everyone
run along this is awesome baby oh oh yes